as women women do leave if they then
don't make enough money if women out
earn the men they leave the average
woman but I feel like that the average
woman
you are the average woman I mean the
average mindset woman the average
mindset
and I definitely don't you definitely
you just said that and everyone tells me
I don't I'm Different
I promise you okay what makes you
different because I I'm just I feel like
I'm very deep and I've just learned I've
really taken that time out to study life
and to understand how life is I'm 32 now
okay eight last month so I feel like
I've taken time out from in to go
inwards and to learn about life and to
just you know be more not logical but be
more um on point I don't know how to
explain it but I don't think my mindset
is average I don't think I will ever be
average and I really believe in myself